my body i think is going like that's a
reaper that's a reaper that's a reaper
and it's shutting down
hey what's going on everybody it's shawn
evans host of first we feast hot ones
coming at you from williamsburg brooklyn
and you guys tweet me hot sauces all the
time sean you gotta try this shawn you
gotta try that and this might come as a
shock to you but i do not have time to
just be chugging hot sauce all day long
so today i'm gonna meet up with my hot
sauce guru noah from heatnest and he's
gonna show me that new [ __ ] that pure
uncut high-grade colombian hot sauce and
who knows we might even be able to get a
couple bottles for season three so come
on let's go mix it up let's push not
full
shawn good to see you good to see you
buddy how you been been good i like what
you've done with the counter here thanks
well today is an exceptional day we
actually have some hot ones in stock
normally it's as soon as we can get them
out of the kitchen they're out the door
how are hot ones fans when they come
into
the store because i have a feeling that
they're an excitable bunch they seem to
be hot once fans are a special breed
they come in
sort of check out the shelves quietly
and they see that hot ones isn't there
and it's almost like they're asking for
something yo you got the the hot ones
like all that back room a lot of people
come in here trying to recreate the
experience of hot ones that you've made
on the show so they'll try and do a
lineup of 10 sauces and sequence things
and get the order right the super in
touch hot ones fans realize that it's
not just about a progression
it's about creating this sort of hot
sauce symphony because all hot sauces
are different absolutely and you have
different pepper types that are going to
affect you in different ways somewhere
the heat hits right up front and and you
can definitely see this in the
interviews when some of the people you
know they can get you know 10 seconds
into the answer before it actually hits
them yes um so you know the ghost pepper
has a bit of that delay versus you know
habanero you're going to feel right away
in the back your throat all right i want
to talk about the landscape of hot sauce
for a second because maybe it's just
like i'm in that storm and it feels this
way but everybody keeps talking about
hot sauce but something that you always
carry with you hot sauce for anyone who
loves hot sauce they know once you're in
you're in there's only one direction to
go you just keep getting more engaged
you keep getting more acclimatized and
accustomed to it and you want it with
every meal and you go a little bit
spicier
you don't go the other direction and
that's like almost a warning to people
out there if you start getting into hot
sauce and instead of feeling discomfort
with the feeling that it puts in your
mouth you sort of start to fall in love
with it forget about it like you have a
new it's a new person now you're now a
reborn person it's like a drug in some
ways but if you reach this point where
you can eat something super hot and you
just get this euphoric high well you
know yes yes that's all i'm doing all
i'm doing is chasing the dragon like
everybody thinks i have this show to pay
my rent i don't like it's just because i
need my fix all right noah i can talk to
you about hot sauce all day but this is
a business trip season three is coming
at us and it's coming at us quick and we
might need some new sauces in the mix so
let's go do some shopping absolutely
so in thinking about what would work
well on wings and play a part in this
symphony definitely a lot of good
options i'm here in brooklyn queen
majesty red habanero and black coffee
red habanero is a hotter variety of
habanero and the black coffee in here
would give some really dark notes that
would play well on the wings and be a
good contrast to a lot of the louisiana
style flavors that you've had in the
past adobo loko's hamajang this is from
maui hawaii this is a smoked ghost
pepper sauce an apple cider vinegar
personally i really like this on wings a
lot uh when you smoke the peppers you
round out the edges on the heat so it
sort of smooths out the ghost pepper but
like you know the ghost pepper still
will come at you
yes
it uh it chases you it's not burning
from here it's like coming from inside
up one thing that we're seeing a lot of
these days in sauces is smoky this is
with tamarind so a little sweet lots of
smoke from those ancho merida peppers is
from san antonio texas it's almost like
a barbecue hot sauce dirty dicks hot
sauce is awesome on wings this is from
vermont this is another habanero sauce
on the hotter side this is the second
half sauce when we start to get up to
the higher heat stuff oh so this is some
muscle right here the bull fighter i
mean just look at the color on that that
you can tell it's going to do some
damage this is a pablo's out of evans
georgia and the bull fighters with aged
ghost peppers and aged red habanero and
a little bit of cherry that's for that
touch of sweet
i've got a couple of limited editions in
our test kitchen out back something to
really get our spice on
all right so what you're looking at here
is this sort of makeshift hot ones
lineup that's been curated by noah but
noah before we start i need to know what
do you think of the lineup that we
currently have are there any blind spots
are there things you think we can
improve i've had almost all the sauces
you have in the lineup i'm not going to
say anything bad about anyone but i
think the hot ones fans know how you
feel about some of them pain 100 to me
is the worst tasting hot sauce or you'd
never put this on a sandwich mad dog 357
is a tougher sauce to endure
than blair's are you saying this so to
make me eat this one where we see wings
now going in a lot of fun directions
what people are doing is really
reimagining the wings we see a lot of
sweet stuff a lot of smoky stuff
in addition to super hot stuff all right
let's kick it up then all right so let's
start off with this uh ancho and merida
peppers so this i think there's tamarind
in here and whenever you have a sweet
fruit like tamarind that's gonna pair
really well with you know the richness
of the wings that's good that's tasty
this is a good sauce one you know what i
think that would do is that would be
like
oh
your little weird waynes world set here
like maybe this isn't such a freak show
because we'd open with a sauce that
people actually like to taste we want to
lull them into that sense of security
right exactly okay next up let's really
switch it up this is our mustard and
horseradish sauce with a little bit of
that dark rum in there
big mustard in that it'll light you up a
little bit though oh yeah it's a
reminder hey this is a you're on hot
ones yeah
this ain't burning questions so next up
let's do uh the hellacious hot sauce i
think this one's kind of funny because
the skull and crossbones on the label
it's really not too hot this is
definitely a first half sauce
[Music]
that's a good hot spot all right next up
we've got the secret aardvark drunken
jerk this one's habanero also a little
bit of rum in there and this one has
lots of rich spices
oh that's gotta be on a burger that's on
pizza whatever i'm tasting right now
dirty dicks very aggressive brand this
is the only sauce i've ever seen and
really like that had banana and you'll
definitely get the banana nuts big time
get the banana i'm a huge banana fan
it's gr noah you're knocking it out of
the park right now i gotta be real with
you we have a queen majesty red habanero
and black coffee yeah i'm curious on
this one so in here balance with a
little bit of ginger
keep it fresh
not overpowering the red habaneros no
but pretty hot yeah so this is hamajang
this is smoked ghost pepper with some
habanero in there too uh oh and this is
smoked with kiawah a hawaiian wood
layered yeah layered heat wise because
this has a habanero
and the ghost it is gonna work in that
same effect and it's gonna it's a little
time delayed too yeah that's the ghost
actually
takes that same approach but brings it
up to 10.
this is the bullfighters this is the red
habanero so that's going to hit you in
the back of the throat punch right away
and then just as that passes is when the
ghost pepper kicks in before we start
just because i'm slowing you down a
little bit but i do actually have a
really important question because it
comes up all the time and it's this
thing about scoville units so the fans
are always like what is it fifteen
like we've [ __ ] up the graphics like a
million times some people get upset
about scoville units in that way but
they also i think put a lot of reliance
on scoville units and what i've always
thought is that marketers really take
advantage of scoville units and they're
like this taco's 9 million scoville
do people mess with scovilles too much
should people rely on scovilles do they
matter what's the deal with scovilles
personally i think it is probably abused
a bit too much the reality is like if
something was 9 million scoville
all right that's a lot hotter than
pepper spray so the you know nine
million scoville taco would be like you
know getting pepper sprayed in the face
for 10 minutes all right so this one i
can tell it's hot it's our nose is
starting to run a little bit that's how
i know i'm doing a cannonball into the
deep end noah
[Music]
okay coming in
coming in not so bad but it has that
heat thing that you know it's gonna hit
you later
when i taste and i know and here it
comes and here it comes that's
[Music]
yeah that's a good hot that's a good
what are we putting that one at is that
about eight that about nine
that's probably yeah sitting at about an
eight minute up there
and keep in mind you're a professional
so when you have a guest on the show
they're not in the same league that you
play at yes that is gonna be quite hot
all right so this one is szechuan
peppercorn and ghost pepper szechuan
peppercorn of course is the famous
tongue tingling numbing one uh and this
has about 18 ghost peppers in each
bottle i like to say it burns your soul
like this one tastes expensive i know it
doesn't make sense but it does it's a
rich sauce yeah they didn't have to use
much vinegar here there wasn't much room
left after all the ghost peppers
sometimes in the afternoon i just need
my fix and i'll take a little hummus and
a little of this mix it together just
put that on a cracker just to just to
get me back to normal if that's number
nine
obviously there's only there's not so
much room to that ceiling but there is a
little bit this means we're going up a
notch yeah and uh
up here we have this we don't keep on
the shelves this is a super limited
edition this is a reaper sauce and this
is pure reaper so what i got for you
here today if yes i'll take it a little
too hot i got you a little
whipped cream
let me kind of bring up something that
drives me nuts because i feel like
people always try to tell me they give
me tips for dealing with hot food and
i'm always like dude are you [ __ ]
crazy i've had the hottest hot sauces
i've eaten reapers like you don't know
anything i don't know but low-key water
does maybe it's just psychological but
if i have an ice water on the table and
my mouth is dying i will reach for that
ice water and i feel like it does help
me or it cools my mouth or there's
something that it does that works for me
is that just in my head or is that
instantaneous relief but as soon as that
water's out of your mouth you're right
back where you started all right oh my
god looks like we got a clump this is uh
it's a professional portion for a
professional
don't try the things we do
[Music]
okay so instantly
that's instant
you know what it is is it's like
pavlov's dog
where like i taste it and instantly i'm
back to the basement at jimmy's 43. i'm
back in central park
with chili klaus and my body i think is
going like that's a reaper that's a
reaper that's a reaper and it's shutting
down
it's going into self-defense mode it's
going into self-defense shields up but i
don't think jesus
but tasty right
that's the thing
about the reaper is it just is like
such a
powerful and like robust and profound
taste exactly it's like eating a steak
when you have a taste of this yeah just
one little drop
damn well i have one special thing here
uh this was a gift from our friend brody
dawson and this is a jar 100 ghost
peppers for our brothers at heatonness
because why not
sometimes we get a little bored and want
to send our brothers and heat a little
treat this jar contains exactly 100
ghost peppers mashed with just enough
vinegar to get them moving around it's
really hot so don't [ __ ] with it okay in
the right direction
okay
so in the same way that like you really
taste the reaper on the reaper one
you taste the ghost on this right away i
think that might be have something to do
with you know there'd be 100 ghost
peppers in there yeah ghost army
all right noah thank you a lot to digest
here in more ways than one i'm gonna go
back take these findings compared to the
algorithm
maybe a sauce or two here will end up in
season three if i'm going off the rip
let me tell you the ones i like number
one in this i love this
low-key dirty dicks great hot sauce and
then when we work our way
up here
pablo's and the hummer homogenous can't
go wrong with those either so i'm gonna
take all the notes back
take it over to the brain trust over at
hot ones you know we've got our finest
men just
punched in algorithms balancing
equations and we'll figure it all out
keep sending us your suggestions
tweet them at first we feast send them
to me do whatever you got to do noah
always a blast when you have me over at
eatonist i appreciate it man i'll see
you soon i love it keep up the good
stuff
[Music]
you